if people in your town suddenly started
dying horrible deaths what would you do
everyone you love is getting murdered by
a mysterious plague and the truth behind
what is causing it is more terrifying
than anyone can imagine i'm going to
break down the mistakes made what you
should do and how to beat the mysterious
plague in cheeky this doctor here has no
idea that everyone he loves is about to
die toshio here is the town of sodoba's
best doctor and who has just been tasked
with inspecting a recent crime scene on
the outskirts of town this woman who
died of natural causes along with her
husband and their neighbor next door who
are both mutilated as hell however
something is off because toshio can tell
that the wife of this couple died
several days after the husband and their
neighbor which if that's true means that
this lady was living with a mutilated
corpse for a whole week before she died
herself without telling anyone about it
the police think it's just wild dogs but
toshio knows that this horror show
wasn't caused by wild dogs and he's
right because later he gets a call from
a house nearby someone from the village
has just gotten sick okay this peaceful
little village has already faced what i
would describe to be a horrifying
situation and the fact that this
happened in a small village makes this
even worse because being in a small town
means that anyone nearby could be next
now the wild dog theory is highly
unlikely but even if it were true all it
would take for them to confirm this
theory would be to see if any of the
entrance doors were open and if there
were any paw prints or marks left within
the house or any dog hairs or urine from
dogs i doubt any wild dog would be able
to open a door properly without leaving
some scratch marks nor be able to have
wiped their paws perfectly before
entering the house i mean i guess
anything is possible but i highly doubt
this theory is worth following up on and
another reason why death by wild dogs is
super unlikely is because unlike dom's
hometown of thailand japan having stray
dogs just in general is a highly rare
occurrence due to article 6 clause 9 of
the rabies prevention law in japan which
states that stray dogs must be impounded
and disposed of within a set amount of
time if no owner comes forward making
japan's kill rate of their nation's cats
and dogs to be over 200 000 a year but
that's a story for another day something
this huge happening in such a small
village would put me on edge and the
police taking this lightly this is going
to cost them toshio then rushes over to
the sick girl's house where we see her
laying there sleepy and in a daze and
who the doc thinks has a mild case of
anemia and so he takes a blood sample
and tells her to get some rest however
later pink hair girl begins to have
insane visions of a creepy blonde woman
and passes out and things are about to
get a whole lot more sinister because
the next morning toshio gets a call and
finds out that the very same pink girl
he took a blood sample from has
mysteriously died and no one knows how
tosho then asks the family if he can do
an autopsy but they demand that he get
the hell out instead forcing the town's
best qualified doctor to leave even more
clueless than he was before the next day
the village holds a wake for pink hair
girl and the whole town shows up
including this big city kid to turn
small village student natsuno and this
dude is so cold and calloused it's
disgusting and i love it because this
wake only makes him want to get the hell
out of this town even more however
little does he realize that he'll soon
join this girl instead later that day at
the only hospital in sodoba toshio
finally receives the results of pink
hair girl's blood test and what he is
about to discover could not be more
insane tosho discovers that pink hair
girl didn't have what he thought which
was my acidic hypochromic anemia aka
iron deficiency anemia the most common
type of anemia out there but instead
finds out that she had normal acidic
normochromic anemia which is usually
caused by bleeding however toshio says
that when he examined pink hair girl he
didn't find any visible wounds or
internal bleeding meaning he doesn't
know how her body shut down so quickly
and since they couldn't do an autopsy on
her he had no clue what went wrong the
hospital suddenly then gets a call from
another family that someone else in the
village has died this time being an old
man who appears to have died from a
summer cold and anemia just like pink
hair girl okay what did i say before if
i was in the big city i wouldn't think
twice about a death or two whatever it
happens but the fact that multiple
people died within the last week within
this tiny town makes me nervous as hell
now a summer cold is simply a cult that
people usually catch during but not
limited to the summer with the most
common symptoms from this being a runny
nose coughing congestion headaches
pressure in the head or sinus low energy
and muscle ache among other things it's
basically a collection of symptoms
rather than a defined disease and it's
normally a mild illness that usually
resolves itself within a few days
although complications from the initial
cold is when things can get serious and
it's also when the initial mild symptoms
can evolve into a serious illness such
as developing into a respiratory
infection especially within people who
have already compromised or weak immune
systems like the elderly this is why i
wouldn't be as concerned if the deaths
piling up so far have been old people
ages 65 years and older but the fact
that a young girl has also kicked the
bucket makes me think that this is a
huge cause for concern and the main part
about anemia being present is simply a
condition that can develop in people
suffering from various flus and certain
other infections this means that the
anemia itself is not an uncommon thing
to develop from having these sniffles
and isn't a factor that i'd be super
concerned with yet because the usual
go-to method for treating anemia is to
simply treat the underlying disease
present but because we don't know
exactly what is going on yet makes me
think that this isn't your average
summer cold and again a young girl just
died and seemingly overnight i think
it's time guys to take this a little bit
more seriously and maybe break out the
lysol and start spraying everybody's
face as soon as possible toshio is
shocked to the core but he doesn't even
have time to piece his thoughts together
because just then another call comes in
about someone else having died overnight
and this time tosho heads out even more
cautious than he's ever been before he
finds out that this old lady died
strangely overnight right after feeling
sleepy and dazed the whole day before
and that she didn't want this crying old
lady to take her to the hospital this is
the last straw for toshio who now after
seeing over seven people die within the
last half of a month thinks something
seriously strange and worrying is going
on around town causing him to later meet
up with his best friend and junior monk
seishin along with an official from the
town hall to report on the number of
residents who have died within this
month but what's strange is that the
town official informs toshio that even
more people have died from this unknown
plague than he initially thought but
they didn't report it earlier because
the victims died in the neighboring town
they weren't originally included in this
town officials death records toshio's
heart thuds in his chest as he realizes
that this may be the start of a
terrifying epidemic with victims
initially having very minor symptoms
that will soon kill within a few days
which means they have to hurry potosio
tries to keep everyone cool and in check
and he tells them to not tell anyone
about this epidemic as they still have
no concrete proof and without proof they
don't have anything and so toshio and
seishin set out to get to work with
toshio the next day getting back a new
blood sample from the latest victim in
town this purple hair girl with the same
problem as all the rest anemia basically
all the things that leaves this good
doctor even more stumped than before not
realizing that the explanation to all of
this dates back centuries okay let's
cool it on the scientific mr smart guy
terms for a sec now a reticulocyte is
simply a red blood cell that is still
developing think of them like baby blood
cells not yet fully matured and an
increase in reticulocyte count can rise
when there's a lot of blood loss or in
certain diseases in which red blood
cells are destroyed prematurely such as
hemolytic anemia and the rest of the
stuff that toshio mentioned such as
nucleated erythrocyte and hyperplasia of
erythroblasts are basically various
conditions that can happen within the
body all as a result of a lack of red
blood cells this is what we know so far
however i would also consider the body's
response towards the sudden changes in
red blood cell count that is why i would
also look into the possibility of
hemorrhagic shock happening within the
victims and to top that off the symptoms
between anemia and hemorrhagic shock are
similar this means that what toshio
thinks could be anemia could be as a
result from hemorrhagic shock so if we
go with this hypothesis if i was toshio
i would begin looking into any visible
injuries external or internal to confirm
if this is indeed what is going on
here's the thing with such a crazy
sickness like this i would inspect each
and every nook and cranny on the skin of
the victims because all of this could be
from a simple insect bite which goes to
show how important it is that we examine
any and all cuts that could be on the
body no matter how small or
insignificant they may appear all of a
sudden a couple then bust through the
hospital doors with this sick chick
looking even worse than when the doctor
saw her yesterday and toshio yells out
in anger and frustration it seems as
though every patient waits until they're
on their deathbed before even stepping
foot in a hospital it's almost as if
they're being instructed to avoid the
hospital and toshio then notices for the
first time these insect bites on this
girl's arm right as the team of doctors
admit her into the hospital but toshio
isn't done with his questions as he then
begins to pry heavily into the boyfriend
of the sick girl asking him if he's been
in contact with anyone who could have
passed on this summer cold to them and
that's when the boyfriend mentions that
the only people that they met up with
until now was with a new couple who just
recently moved into a castle up on the
hill a couple that could only be
described as having the coldest look
about them with pitch black eyes and
wondrous mint skin eternally beautiful
but toshio is all about the sick and
disregards the boyfriend's creepy
commentary heading back in to check on
the girl but it's hopeless as she dies
later on anyways adding yet another body
to the town's death records and the
doctor himself not one step closer to
figuring any of this out later that
night though natsuno stops by his best
friend's house toru who later goes to a
coffee vending machine and meets the
strangest pale skinned male around their
age this blue-haired guy who mentions
that he also just moved into the house
on the hill and who gets invited by toru
to come chill at his house sometime for
a video game night and blue haired guy
graciously accepts mentioning that he'll
bring another friend to join them in on
the fun soon that same night natsu no
dreams of the very first victim who he
found out about pink hair girl as she
appears in the distance glaring back at
our boy with blood red eyes closing in
with a smirk that could kill until he
suddenly wakes up in the dead of night
to an empty room the days pass as this
mysterious plague sweeps through the
town raiding even the town's finest of
their lives and the residents mentioned
that the families of those deceased have
begun moving away the same night of the
victim's deaths no funeral no goodbyes
no nothing leaving the rest of the town
more stumped than ever as to what the
hell is happening and it keeps getting
worse because on one fateful day after
receiving the blood sample of yet
another recently deceased victim toshio
takes it upon himself to finally alert
the staff on what he thinks is going on
as his ingenious mind finally connects
the dots or so he thinks with 19 dead so
far they're running out of time and
toshio thinks that this is truly an
epidemic but not one that's ever been
documented before but before they can
ask the town officials or even the
government for help they need to gather
the data starting with their only lead
the condition of normocytic normochromic
anemia that same night the sleepy town
of soda bud then braces itself for yet
another promising night of death as
natsuno stays over at toru's house only
to toss and turn late at night with a
gloomy feeling of someone watching over
him seeing none other than pink hair
girl yet again as she glides throughout
the house and towards the boy's room
coming for her prey until natsuno
finally wakes up and he glares around
only to see his best friend safe and
sound except he looks awfully pale and
almost as if he just woke up from the
dead but that's just a coincidence
natsuno thinks toshio's best friend
seishin finds out from some more
neighbors that a lot of people have
begun to leave the town only to
mysteriously die later as if they knew
their time was up and they left knowing
that they would never return alive and
the news only gets worse for our simple
town folk because at school that day
natsuno suddenly notices that toru isn't
there and hears from a girl that he's at
home playing a new video game that he
got but natsuno doesn't trust her and he
heads straight for his best friend's
house right as he arrives he sees his
beloved bro toru just as he left him
last tucked in with a resting face paler
than a living corpse except this time
he's more corpse than living
nope nope nobody nope nope nope
something is definitely going on and it
ain't no simple case of blood disorder
we're seeing freaking ghosts right now
and now our best friend is dead now this
could have been a simple case of sleep
paralysis which can happen when your
brain begins to wake up but your body is
still in sleep mode resulting in you
being awake but paralyzed for a few
moments until your body snaps out of it
and with sleep paralysis it can be very
common to hallucinate scary people or
creatures near your bed particularly if
you happen to be conscious during the
rapid eye movement or rem cycle of sleep
this is what i would have initially
blamed seeing pink hair girl early on
however now with our friend dying
literally the morning after we saw her
this makes me think that this is way too
much of a coincidence if i was not snow
i take matters into my own dang hands
and visit the only place that could
provide us with answers the clinic and
because this isn't no proper giant
hospital this makes me think that the
protocols and security measures in
diverging sensitive information to
people wouldn't be as strict as if we
were in a hospital in a big city so i
think we have a very good chance of
simply walking in and finding the town's
superstar doctor toshio himself because
he's likely the only one who will be
able to separate the town's speculation
from facts and the fact that we
essentially predicted our friend's death
can mean a few things and may or may not
have to do with quantum entanglement
hear me out now like albert einstein
once said quantum entanglement is
basically the signs of spooky [ __ ]
happening at a distance and this could
explain what we saw like someone who
predicted their best friend's death
right before it happened spooky
occurrences like this have actually been
linked to quantum biology which is
basically the science of studying [ __ ]
that doesn't follow the normal laws of
physics in short the science behind how
natsuno saw his best friend die before
his time could have either been dumb
luck or a phenomenon rooted in actual
science somehow or confirmed to us that
we actually did see pink hair girl back
from the dead and that she is actually
somehow responsible for our best
friend's death a wave of dread suddenly
spills over natsuno as his world
suddenly plunges into a darkness that he
never thought possible because this time
he believes with his entire being that
pinker girl is behind this and he's
going to find out how the next day then
comes revolving back as if it were the
day before with another patient dead and
more families mourning toshio sits deep
in thought refusing to give into the
worst plague of his career right as he
goes through the usual examination
routine noticing another insect bite on
the arm of the deceased and he collects
another blood sample tosho then later
meets up with seishin to update him on
his investigation into the villagers of
the town and seishin mentions that he's
coming across some strange findings
noting that more and more people have
begun leaving town only to die a few
days later thinking it to be connected
to the epidemic somehow but toshio has
heard enough of this and tells him to
shut his four-eyed face up thinking his
efforts to do nothing with the epidemic
and that he's wasted all of his time for
nothing and he retreats back into what
is my well-being his clinic of corpses
and the corpse fest continues in the
form of film flattery as natsuno begins
spending his nights researching the
monsters of hollywood hoping to find
some insight into just what kind of
monster pink hair girl is or he believes
is just as then this kid comments on the
zombie film that natsuno is watching and
mentions that it reminds him of the town
legend that he grew up with within this
village the legend of the okiagari also
known as the dead who rise at night and
they would come back from beyond the
grave to punish children who misbehaved
or so the folklore says and this strikes
a chord with natsuno because thanks to
this guy he now knows that he's onto
something okay okay while it might seem
silly this could actually be our best
bet in gaining some insight into what
the hell is going on because from the
looks of things they really don't have
the internet which means films is our
only means of trying to find mirror
examples of what we're experiencing in
real life the brain naturally likes to
find patterns in things so let's use it
to our advantage in this case because
our town's doctors can't figure out what
the hell is going on so this is the next
best thing because such things like the
undead and ghouls initially came from
such places like folklore back before we
could explain everything with science to
suggest why certain things the way they
were in fact a very popular theory of
how zombies were made comes from a
scientist by the name of david wade who
claimed to have found a neurotoxin in a
powder used by magicians in which they
would make the victim fall into a deep
coma appearing to be dead and within a
few days after the funeral the victim
would then be awoken by the magician
again giving off the illusion that they
were a zombie so while a lot of what of
the films say about zombies and the
undead may be complete [ __ ] there
might be a few hints of truth hidden
within that we could use to better
understand what's going on because
remember we saw pink hair girl appear in
our dreams as some freaky zombie thing
and then our best friend died within the
next day and also at this moment modern
day science can't really explain the
[ __ ] that is going on right now however
the fact remains that there are
thousands of films and books written on
the subject of scary-ass paranormal [ __ ]
which means we could potentially find
certain instances within folklore to
explain what the hell is going on and
remember no internet so i would utilize
the town's library for any more books
based on mythological lore anything we
could use to help explain what we saw
the next day natsuno confronts toshio
about pink hair girl since toshio was
the one who examined her corpse and
wrote up her death certificate but
toshio assures him that she was
definitely dead when he examined her
with rigor mortis already setting in by
the time he arrived he reassures worried
not to know that there's no way she
could be alive unless she took a page
right out of hollywood and came back as
a zombie or a vampire this sends a wave
of realization down natsuno's spine and
he heads off abruptly leaving tosho
confused as all hell and makes him
suspect that this is in fact not an
epidemic after all elsewhere two curious
kids stake out the castle on the hill
and this kid sure [ __ ] believes that he
saw one of the recently deceased enter
the castle and these poor kids are
completely unaware that blue haired guy
is staking them out from the shadows and
watching then later as they walk back
natsuno spots them and mentions that
they were just being watched until he
realizes that just like him they think
something is going on in that mansion
too and the two kids hear that natsuno
suspects everything that's gone wrong
including the deaths pink hair girl and
even blue haired guy are all due to the
fact that they are okieagari undead who
have risen from the grave and that's why
natsuno has been seeing pink hair girl
in his dreams because she's come back
straight from the dead this solidifies
these kids believe that the dead person
they saw enter the castle is also an
okiyagari however natsuno says that they
need to know for sure which is why he
suggests that they dig up pink hair
girl's grave in order to find out
clearly not caring about any decency for
the dead later back at the clinic tosho
invitation over to discuss his findings
findings that will change the course of
history for the worst satian interrupts
toshio to tell him that recently all the
death certificates from the town have
gone missing meaning now they don't have
the proper paperwork to officially prove
how many people they lost in the village
meaning they won't be able to call the
government for help but toshio couldn't
care less and mentions that what's going
on isn't an epidemic after all that all
of these deaths are happening because of
the okie gauri or more specifically in
layman terms vampires this casts a
fainting spell oversation who begs tosho
to tell him that he's joking but tough
[ __ ] he isn't because it's one thing to
die from hemorrhagic shock but what
disease would cause people to quit their
job and physically move away and tosho
mentions that these creatures are
probably using hypnosis on their victims
as they feed on them ordering them to
move towns away right before their death
and in this way they've managed to
prevent the town's death rate from ever
going up at least officially okay so
they were dead wrong about them being
zombies which actually makes a whole lot
more sense however one thing that
doesn't make sense is how some of them
are able to withstand sunlight like blue
hair guy because he clearly was watching
the two kids in broad daylight but let's
put a pin in this one for now because at
this point all signs are pointing to the
worst and most insane scenario that
vampires are okiyagari are the cause
behind all of this which means we need
to be sure that seishin actually
believes us because i'll admit this
scary fact can't be a tough pill to
swallow and from here on out we can't
have anyone on our side who has any
doubts about this now that we know
what's going on it's pretty darn likely
that we'll eventually come face to face
with the okie gari soon enough
especially once they know that we know
about them if i'm toshio i'd start by
revealing that these bug bites aren't
bug bites at all but actually bite marks
from agari on all of the past victims
and actually find some way to prove it
to him that these biomarks were made by
okiyagari and not by something from
nature and because of all of this toshio
now has a plan starting with the latest
soon to be victim who toshio invites to
stay at his clinic overnight knowing
that whatever monster is sucking her dry
will be forced to pay them a visit
tonight elsewhere the gang visits the
burial site ultimately discovering that
the coffin which they thought was filled
for so long is in fact empty then
suddenly a cold pair of hands abduct
this little girl and plunge her deep
within the entrouted forest and are
about to bite into her flesh before she
reveals a holy token right in front of
this monster's face stopping him just
long enough before natsuno swings a
shovel right into his face knocking him
out they quickly feel his pulse and
realize that this beast doesn't have one
making him officially part of the undead
shocking the gang to the core natsuno
quickly then says to bury his corpse to
see if he rises up again tomorrow and so
they begin shoveling working through the
dead of night until this guy's cold limp
body gets buried six feet deep then
after a sleepless night they return the
next day and what they discover only
confirms what they dare hope wasn't true
that the corpse that they buried last
night just like pink hair girl rose up
back from the grave solidifying their
suspicions that their small town of
sodoba has been invaded by okiyagari
this little kid suddenly has had enough
of this freak show and demands that they
charge right up to the mansion on the
hill and attack whatever monsters lay
dormant within but natsuno stops him
dead in his tracks because the cold hard
truth is that they don't know what
they're up against whether they're in
fact a zombie or a vampire because that
blue-haired kid was spotted checking
them out in broad daylight meaning that
whatever they do they need to figure out
what they're up against first how many
of them are there and most importantly
how to kill them natsuno then suggests
that they test out the stake to the
heart theory for the next person that
inevitably will fall victim to this
plague because they need to figure out
how to stop these monsters soon okay
this is insane we finally know what the
hell is going on sorta except now it's
even more terrifying since we don't know
anything else natsuno is in a pretty
tight spot right now we don't know
exactly what these creatures are they
are similar to vampires but they're not
exactly like vampires how do we kill
them because all we got so far is to
rely on what the movies tv shows and
books have told us but does any of that
[ __ ] actually work on them until we find
that out i wouldn't stake my life on
coming face to face with any one of them
however what natsuno said is a solid
place to start a stake through the heart
and i'd also maybe add severing the
human head and setting them on fire as a
means of taking them out because while
sunlight and maybe across to their face
might not harm them relying on attacking
or ideally obliterating the two most
important organs the brain and the heart
will probably be a good way to kill them
without necessarily knowing that it'll
work beforehand the heart sends blood
throughout the body and to the brain and
it also provides the body with oxygen
and various nutrients the brain is
basically a one-stop shop for everything
that the body needs in order to function
it is the command center for the nervous
system and vampire or okio gauri or not
there's little possibility that they'll
be able to function without a head
attached to their body i don't care how
scary they are there are some things
that can't break the laws of science
people and living without your head is
probably one of them until we know more
i'd stick to impaling the heart severing
the head or setting them on fire during
the cover of daylight at least for now
because there's almost no shot that one
of those methods won't work that same
night toshio and station set up for what
will likely be the most horrifying night
of their life so far and they take watch
over the latest plague victim as she
lays resting in the hospital room
because despite everything toshio knows
that these monsters have taken their
time killing their prey so far since all
the victims up until now have taken 4
days to die meaning that due to the
sheer amount of blood within the human
body these horrifying creatures on
average probably take days to completely
drain their victims dry toshio also
thinks that these undead creatures
inject some sort of toxin into their
victims to prevent them from crying out
for help during the whole process much
like some insect species that inject a
narcotic substance into their prey to
let them feed in peace whatever the case
may be toshio is sure that these demons
will strike again tonight later tosho
and seishin await outside the room of
their patient just as they hear the old
lady call out her whereabouts making
toshio suspect that the undead are
nearby and he's right because he goes up
to the only other point of entry and
pulls down the blinders revealing the
most horrifying thing a pair of
blood-red eyes attached to a floating
corpse and this edward cullen wannabe
floats back down to the floor right
before toshio angrily blasts over the
window and declares that he'll knock
their teeth in if they set one foot
inside that hospital and this thank god
non-shiny bloodsucker keeps her distance
and toshio safely secures this frail old
lady's soul from damnation for another
night okay there's little reason to
think that vampires or okyo ghari's last
night didn't enter because he didn't
feel like it he didn't enter because he
couldn't and this is one advantage that
we now know for sure because right now
we're kind of screwed because it won't
be long before that one vampire brings
reinforcements which means we gotta go
balls to the wall from here on out and
this means letting the others know
finally about what the hell is really
going on keeping it secret isn't helping
anyone i would use the advantage of
daylight to inform all the staff that
were planning a very important meeting
late at night and i would purposely
stash melee weapons of all types in and
around the floor of where the old lady
is being held before night comes around
then using the cover of a meeting i'd be
able to have all the nurses and doctors
from the clinic gather within the same
room as the old lady while we wait for
the vampires i mean okie ghari to come
back because informing our colleagues
that this plague is actually the result
of okie agari will be a tough sell and
we're better off showing them now of
course by the time the okiragari do
arrive they'll be unprepared as hell and
we'll be expecting such a huge conflict
to arise which by the way is the exact
reason why i'd stash as many weapons
around the room and floor of our patient
because when these okie gauri inevitably
come back and our colleagues finally see
firsthand how horrifying these things
are i'm pretty sure then they won't mind
grabbing a gun and helping out and
besides even if they decide to not help
me they'd at least make for some really
sweet meat shields for me and seishin to
try and take some pot shots at nature's
most horrifying creation the next day
arrives as they come to discover their
old lady patient is actually recovering
meaning that they've just discovered how
to reverse the sickness toshio and
station then take five to bless the
japanese gods for their luck so far
before they begin preparing themselves
for another night of horror sheen is
starting to suspect that if the legends
and movies are right then that okie gari
didn't enter last night because it
needed permission to enter and enter
they won't because then our dual heroes
begin preparing for another night of
chaos as darkness finally sets again
over the hospital and just then the
power goes out forcing these two to rush
back into the old ladies room only to
see through the hospital window that
this place is now surrounded by
okiyagari and toshio doesn't even have a
chance to prepare himself for battle
because blue-haired guy comes up from
behind and knocks him out shocking our
two heroes into wondering who and what
these creatures really are including
blue-haired guy the dark then stumbles
to his feet and heads to the window and
he's forced to witness his beloved
patient to get brutally slaughtered by
the rest of the okiyagari horde killing
her before evading into the night
instilling more rage into toshio than
ever before and he prepares to ready
himself seishin and anyone else willing
to fight these terrifying monsters head
on setting the stage for the first
official okiyogari war in the history of
the modern day world and if you want to
help us fight the okio gari don't forget
to like comment subscribe and check out
the how to beat playlist down below